this week we're talking about strategy
guides cheat codes and graphics for
Google cloud platform I'm Joanna
and welcome to this week in cloud where
we serve you the lowest latency news
moving to the cloud is important but so
is thinking critically about which parts
of your business it actually makes sense
to move to guide you we've got a post
for all the CIOs currently wrestling
with this question and it will bust your
myths about migrating and detail how
it's possible to decouple dependencies
for more agility without adding
unnecessary complexity like that
sentence virtual display devices for
Chrome Enterprise are now generally
available meaning you can add a virtual
display device to any VM on Google cloud
this gives your VM video graphics array
capabilities without having to use GPUs
which can be powerful but also expensive
get the full scoop on the cloud blog one
of the greatest challenges customers
Faceman onboarding in the cloud is how
to control and protect their assets
while letting their users deploy
resources securely so we created this
series of posts to show you how to write
your security policies as code once and
for all and to apply them both before
and after you deploy resources in your
DCP environment the first post is about
using for study config validator it's no
secret that Google Cloud offers a lot of
products to help you understand the
differences Greg Wilson has a cheat
sheet it's simple all of the
approximately 222 products we offer
explained in four words or less let it
be your light when looking to the cloud
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link have any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us and we'll
see you in the cloud
you